Executive functions are the mental processes
that enable us to plan, focus attention, remember
instructions, and juggle multiple tasks successfully.
We can distinguish between three components:
1. Working memory,
2. Inhibitory control and
3.Cognitive flexibility.
All 3 are interlinked and influence each other.
Psychologist Deborah Phillips from Georgetown University,
calls it the "air traffic control system" of our brain.
Like an air traffic control system has to
manage lots of airplanes
departing and landing with perfect timing,
we have to manage a lot of information and distractions simultaneously.
Without good executive functions, disaster strikes.
Let's look at three different components:
The Working memory is responsible for processing information.
If well developed, it allows us to manage
multiple chunks of information at the same time.
Complex tasks can be solved and deep ideas understood.
Without much of it, our intelligence is limited.
Inhibitory control describes our capability
to concentrate,
regulates our emotions
and controls our behaviour during stressful situations.
It's an essential skill if we want to change
a childhood habit.
Without it, we might have trouble to control our behavior
and can come across as "weird."
Cognitive flexibility is the ability to adapt new tasks
quickly and to change our perspective.
If we have little of it, we can’t adapt,
get stuck in old thoughts and have tunnel vision.
We come across as stubborn and uncooperative.
To demonstrate their roles,
let’s compare two imaginary teenagers: Ann and Jay.
Ann is a working memory monster.
She can keep lots of ideas in her mind at
the given time
and mentally buffers digits to calculate them
in her head.
Even if she gets interrupted or feels a change of emotions,
she realizes, but is still able to continue
what she had started.
Jay’s working memory is tiny.
What Ann solves in her head,
he has to write down.
It's hard for him to read complex sentences
or follow a longer train of thought.
He gets distracted easily and starts thinking
about something else.
At school, Ann is an Inhibitory Control Genius.
She is fully in charge of her emotions
and how they are expressed in her behavior.
If a teacher loses his temper,
she remains calm and friendly.
It's easy for her to focus for long periods of time.
As a result, her work is good and the feedback
on it is positive.
Jay's emotions instantly express themselves
in his behavior,
which he often fails to control.
He can get distracted easily
and hence he has difficulties to finish what he started.
His work remains mediocre.
This can lead to negative feedback and
a lower self esteem.
Ann’s cognitive flexibility is great.
She can change her perspective
and find ways around roadblocks.
At school she adjusts from one subject to
the other in the speed of light.
Jay has problems to solve problems,
because his thinking is inflexible.
To change his perspective in response to
constructive criticism,
takes a lot of his mental energy.
Even simple tasks, like switching from talking
to listening is hard for him.
Others can find this annoying.
Executive function develops mainly during
the first 5 years of our lives.
A caring, playful and nourishing childhood
is our best bet to increase them.
Free play trains our inhibitory control
and games practice our working memory.
Playing an instrument trains our brain to
process the notes,
and to coordinate the right and the left hand simultaneously.
If others are listening, we learn to control
our emotions.
Movement is great as well [P].
In football each situation is new,
ball possession requires quick decisions
and builds cognitive flexibility.
One study showed that kids that walked barefoot
each day for just 16 minutes,
improved their working memory.
Because when they do, they need to keep many
things in mind.
With a lot of practise as kids,
we become real executives of our own mind.
This then allows us to excel in teams
and help solve some of the world's more
complex problems.
And since we are able to focus on them for a long period and don’t give up easily,
success is just a matter of time.
THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE SOME EXECUTIVE FUNCTION,
CAN NOW MAXIMIZE THEIR LEARNING FROM THIS VIDEO.
JUST TURN OFF YOUTUBE, TAKE OUT PEN AND PAPER,
AND SUMMARIZE THE CONCEPT IN YOUR OWN SIMPLE LANGUAGE.
IF YOU FAIL THIS TIME, TRY AGAIN AND THEN
DO IT.